hello and welcome to this video in
another blitz game
yeah the one before that was a game
before that that I lost I did not upload
that it no there are some sometimes they
are games that you don't quite believe
and yeah I reported this for cheating I
feel that was at least account sharing I
don't know it's always don't know what
to do with those those kind of videos
because from the get-go well you know
something is of and that is not a normal
game anymore than I know some people
enjoy those videos I don't know it's
just so frustrating that you sit there
and you waste your time and I mean I
just don't believe this game anyway so
let's look at that look at let's look at
this one and see what happens
it started out with the double pink
arrow and black now with an early c5 and
we get into a position that is very
typical often symmetrical English the
Queen on c7 and the knight on c6
oftentimes can be a problem here
this is why I'm lining up here for 95
Queen f5 who came where's the Queen
going there maybe to h5 yeah I'm going
yeah I mean the Queen ISM is not
protected I would like to have it
protected so that 95 becomes the threat
but yeah we'll see let's see what black
does there is no b5 as a knight it's
just hanging on c6 so there is no
immediately aggressive option available
okay so maybe just prepare 95
now if b5 is there even c5 that
sometimes a cool idea but I think black
can just take it's not such a big deal
okay so 95 1 or not
take take yeah it's not it's not leading
to much okay oops I'm sorry I probably
wanted to recapture on d5 with the night
like 95 95 so that the night stays on d5
at the end black doesn't really have
that many active ideas so I got a bit of
have a bit of time okay where are you
going with this yeah just 95 it's not
going to be bad so let's do it
it's some not exactly the only idea that
I have I mean you cannot even take
because he takes and that makes a
product this is actually a real issue
if black cannot take on d5 what is your
move
oh really I take e five I take F 637
that wins a piece I think my Queen
cannot be trapped now this is a temple
on the Queen now that is now uncovered
wins apiece yeah it's a pretty typical
kind of game they're not coming to d5 is
it's often a bit of an issue in general
he I'm a set up with Queen c7 knight c6
a6 is a little bit passive but okay in
black black was not in in a terrible
shape so all kind of normal I think but
it got really really problematic after
the screen c5 the quincy 5 isn't really
helping I'm not quite sure what black
should do I mean you don't have anything
good available the engine is already
quite skeptical about blacks position
it's just like it's 95 is going to be an
annoying move after this it's it's it's
really really bad and the engine gives
me a winning position already I'm not
too surprised I always also have this
someone before the Queen only has a 7 I
there are many issues there currently
I'm just threatening to take on f6
anything to take on f6 and the best
according to the compass this but it
also doesn't look great I mean I can at
least I probably would take and go
before now Queen a7 and now from here
I'm not quite certain what's best
yeah b5 here we can go b5 and
threatening actually b6 and queen a
queen trap this is very funky trap the
Queen that's nice and it's it's just
disaster opposition you know so just
very bad yeah in the game this is just
giving me a piece after this I also win
a piece and they have got many squares
for the Queen
yeah this doesn't look all that dramatic
from like well it is a fairly passive I
just have more active pieces and black
and snow no great activity available
yeah thanks a lot for watching